[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sur les baleines c'est pourquoi ce oui
il y en a beaucoup
j'habite friable on dirait des
vous direz des voix d'enfants
[Applaudissements]
vous venez donc de haute garonne mais
vous m'aviez dit que vous jouez pour les
vaches
oui alors là c'était en normandie pour
un concert avec l'ensemble euro astres
qui est basé à paris met en jeu un peu
partout mais alors c'est quoi cette
histoire de jouer pour des vaches et ben
une heure avant un concert il y avait un
moment de libre et je me suis dit je
vais jouer ça les a attirés et du coup
je fais ça chaque année assez génial
regardez il ya toutes les vaches et puis
vous au violoncelle juste devant un
homme s'amuse à faire une vidéo selphy
avec un lion en arrière-plan
l'animal leur père s'avance à pas de
loup puis tout à coup le fauve s'élance
sur sa proie inconsciente du danger lui
fait un gros câlin
l'homme est un dresseur installé en
afrique du sud il oeuvre pour la
préservation des espèces menacées comme
les lions bien sûr ces boues devant une
salle pleine à craquer et qui plus est
une femme remplie d'anonymes
bah oui c'est compliqué de savoir qui se
cache derrière ces masques bon pour moi
c'est plutôt rassurant de me dire que là
c'est peut-être pas andy macdowell non
c'est une dame qui a des cheveux des
grands yeux et des oreilles
clémence et fanny 18 ans toutes les deux
reçu leur première injection de vaccin
mais ces étudiantes se le concède en
privé elles ont tendance à oublier le
virus et les gestes barrière dont il ya
beaucoup de monde quand il ya des fous
je mets le masque pour sauver choses
quand on est entre amis on a du mal à
rester
avec un masque à relever c'est aussi
j'ai un truc avec les récits vain des wc
on a beau me dire que c'était fait faut
que ce soit fait par mois pour être soit
bien fait que c'est un endroit qui peut
être vecteur de plein de cochonneries
que soit tout désinfecter jusqu aux
interrupteurs c'est pareil c'est logique
quoi qu écrivain on véhicule plein de
trucs dégueulasses quoi je leur fais pas
ce que je veux ce soit fait au moins je
sais que j'ai la conscience tranquille
je sais que c'est bien fait que mes
enfants ils vont pas sortir une gastro
des toilettes et latrines la maison
pourtant le virus n'a pas disparu il
semble même gagner du terrain ces
derniers jours ci chez les plus de 50
ans l'incidence restent stables voire
diminue chez les moins de 30 ans la
tendance est inversée
le taux d'incidence atteint même les 52
nouveaux cas positifs pour cent mille
habitants
chez les 20-29 ans une hausse de 16
points en une semaine des jeunes parfois
encore réticents à l'idée de se faire
vacciner
j'ai pas assez de recul pour savoir
vraiment qu'est ce qu'il ya dans le
vaccin est ce qui est vraiment y va nous
protéger
quels sont les les conséquences après
dans les années à venir
voilà j'en ai débattu avec une personne
en fin de semaine dernière qui m'a dit
effectivement que si je ne souhaitais
pas me faire vacciner on pouvait me
contraindre à la démission
et de là j'ai dit que fait effectivement
si on on ne contraignait à la démission
que je serai prête à aller jusque là sur
les images on va donc cette femme âgée
de 53 ans qui brandit un pistolet aol
appuyé sur la gâchette quelques giclées
d'eau partant direction de la flamme
olympique bon pas suffisant pour
l'éteindre mais elle a eu le temps de
crier son message de protestation avant
d'être interpellé
et elle serait loin d'être la seule à
s'opposer à la tenue des jo au japon
selon les derniers sondages et on ne
sait pas forcément mais en chine
l'âge légal du départ à la retraite pour
les femmes c'est 50 ans 55 ans à de
rares exceptions lorsqu'elles sont
cadres dirigeantes contre eux 60 ans
pour les hommes c'est une des limites
les plus basses au monde
elle a été fixée dans les années 50 à
l'époque où l'espérance de vie des
femmes tourné justement autour de 50 ans
mais voilà aujourd'hui les femmes
chinoises vive 77 ans pour sa liaison
monter des équipes qu'on fait carrière
et bien elles vivent ce départ à la
retraite comme un repos forcé un jury
essentiellement d'un féminin au côté
très bien froid qui lie
plus de femmes dans du riz que d'hommes
ça n'était jamais arrivé cinq femmes
quatre hommes et spike lee qui est donc
le président il ya aussi tahar rahim il
ya mylène farmer qui est juste là je
vois maggie gyllenhaal je vois
mélanie laurent je voie semble donc en
cause et l'acteur de parasites vous le
connaissez pas son nom mais vous avez
tous du parasite donc vous avez physique
mais sur la vidéo on voit antoine
griezmann tout sourire et surtout on
entend ousmane dembélé c'est lui qui
filme et qu'on entend se moquer du
personnel de l'hôtel d'origine asiatique
toutes ces sales gueules dit-il avant de
se moquer de leur langue propos
choquants condamnable et qui viennent
donc de ressurgir sur twitter sans qu'on
sache vraiment pourquoi à l'époque
dembélé n'avait partager ses images qui
avec quelques proches mais des
internautes
les ont mises en ligne ce week-end et le
tollé a été immédiat plusieurs millions
de vues et des condamnations venues du
monde entier et du coup dans les loges
présidentielle au moment de l'entracte
ja on en traite à la mi dance s'appelle
mi temps en fait c'est vrai que certains
se comporte un peu comme des comme des
divas mais selon lui cette scène aurait
pu se dérouler n'importe où sur la
planète j'aurais utilisé les mêmes
expressions dit il je ne visaient aucune
communauté
il m'arrive d'utiliser ce genre
d'expression en privé avec des amis peu
importe leur origine
il présente ensuite ses excuses aux
personnes qui apparaissent sur les
images idem pour antoine griezmann qui
se dit désolé sur twitter il réfute
toutes les accusations et rappelle son
engagement contre toutes les
discriminations
on verra si ces prises de paroles
suffisent à calmer la polémique
salchaud question budget quand même plus
dépensières donc je compte sur toi pour
me freiner un peu
ben bon courage au futur monsieur
mathilde
la danse de la femelle est moins
impressionnante elle se contente
d'imiter les postures du mal
[Musique]
pourtant malgré les efforts désespérés
de son courtisan
elle finit par s'éloigner pas
suffisamment convaincu par sa
démonstration
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et qu'est ce qu'elles disent on ne sait
pas on sait juste que leur langage est
très complexe en quoi qu'ils se
racontent plein de choses donc vous
pensez que c'est un langage élaborer un
choeur devrions on pense même qu'elles
s'appellent par leur prénom
vraiment oui pardonnez-moi la pause à
tout de suite une minute c'est la pause
on revient tout de suite